Ich bin der einzige auf dieser Bühne, der
persönlich
alles verfolgt hat, von sexuellen
Übergriffen auf Kinder bis hin zu Mord.
Ich bin der einzige auf dieser Bühne, der
die großen Banken
dafür angeklagt hat, Amerikas
Hausbesitzer auszunutzen
strafrechtlich verfolgte gewinnorientierte Colleges, weil
sie unsere Veteranen ausgenutzt haben,
und die Realität davon ist, dass wir
über eine Wahl in 27 Tagen sprechen, bei
der der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten letzte Woche
vor 70 Millionen Amerikanern eine Debattenbühne betrat
und sich weigerte, zu verurteilen  Weiße
Supremacisten
nicht wahr und nicht wahr, es war nicht so, als hätte er
keine Chance gehabt,
er hätte es nicht getan, und dann hat er sich verdoppelt,
und dann sagte er,
als er gedrückt wurde, steh zurück,
steh zu mir, keine Eilmeldung
, hier ist niemand